I've drawn the short straw
first it has nothing to do with
seniority let me just say how pleased I
am to be here both literally and
figuratively I'm glad you're not doing
this in memoriam or that sort of thing
I'm also glad we have a podium I was
afraid we're going to have a setup like
yesterday where dr. Sadler talked with
walking around with their portable
microphone at my age my wife's parting
comment to me each day is not I love you
but is your zipper up and so I don't
have to worry about that this morning
but it's hard to believe that it's been
40 years for many of you that are around
my time back in 1973 when I finished
it's just unbelievable that where those
40 years have gone our children now have
children of their own and it's just been
incredible and then yesterday i'm
sitting in the white coat ceremony
looking at the people that i found it
hard to believe that I was ever that
young and got to thinking about what it
would be like to have them come and see
me and asked me to take my pants down
and just didn't want to go there I do
want to take a moment though for a
personal issue and just thank and the
Saddlers and others who interviewed me
and accepted me into the program those
many years ago it was for me a real shot
in the dark to apply my credentials were
relatively limited as one of the newly
minted Vietnam veterans were not much
else experience with a what would be
kindly be noted as a chequered academic
past despite perhaps some demonstration
of some innate intelligence but
nonetheless they they took a chance on
me and I hope that over the years I've
been able to demonstrate that that was a
reasonable chance to take that you've
gained back the sleep that you might
have lost while I was here and you were
worrying about me but I also like to
think that that was an important part of
our founding as as a program and a
philosophy that I think that we
continued on over the years in my years
as a director of admission I can tell
you that a number of years I look at
some of you here in the audience that I
was part of your applying to the program
you know some of you we took a chance on
also and I'm very pleased to say you
know that as well as I do and I'm
pleased to say there you are and and we
were right to take the chance and
congratulations to you as well I do want
to say as we talked a little bit here
this morning and we'll try and do that
clock is wrong though right yeah okay I
hope that we don't come off pretentious
in terms of our presentations that
you're all sitting here today because of
the work that we did and people like us
did certainly and I realized that is not
the case and that the progress that
we've made has been the work of many
many people know one person has affected
the where we are today but but the
day-to-day work of what you all have
done even if you've never served on a
committee or an organization despite the
numbers that David presented and
provided the kind of care that you did
has been every bit as critical to
getting us as a profession to where we
are today as whatever contributions and
Cindy myself and the others have made so
I thank you for your participation from
that level I don't know if you've had a
chance to look at the PA history a
website which is very well done and I
strongly encourage you to go and look at
that if you have any interest in the
history of the profession there's a
wonderful collection of information
there that we should all be part of they
have a little graphic running down the
side of it with just the timeline of the
history profession sort of like the
thing you see at the natural history
museums that Peabody Museum here at Yale
etc it appears i come from the preso a
cage when pas walked around on their
knuckles but as Burdine said it was a
time when there was a void on the earth
in terms of the earth and pas and we
were without a form but it was during
this time that PA history society calls
the implementation period 1966 about
1972 and the
the evolution and standardization period
nineteen seventy three to nineteen
eighty or so that we heard about this
morning but there must have been
something here in the water at Yale for
those of us that were tending the
program that encouraged us to
participate in the program in the
profession and the growth of the
profession because even though Yale was
not the first PA program is young it was
among the very early ones but thanks to
the efforts of Jack Cole the Saddlers
and the faculty here at Yale Paul mosin
certainly clearly helped you get the PA
program going in and said on the road to
do as well as it has done and at the
same time has promoted the kind of
leadership that again david has referred
to that you're seeing him sitting here
before you in addition to our good
friend diner cushman who couldn't be
here as mary noted and in addition in
the audience we have three people who
have served as vice president speaker of
our house of delegates of our national
organization people who like Elaine
grant in addition to the 28 years that
she gave here has served as chairman of
the nGCP a and I don't hold that against
her particularly Paul mosin who while
from that other program while he was
here at Yale served as the third
president of our national organization
as a founding member of our national
organization a person to whom we owe a
great deal of credit for our profession
and of course all of the Yale graduates
again as David said who served on
whether it's a chapter membership
chapter presents we have enough Charlie
Park is here I saw Carol session
Lovett's john dale injure saberi Susan
here Mary Warner herself shooting Nunes
who have all served as president of our
chapter state chapter and helped again
to get us from the early stages that we
heard earlier to where we are today and
hopefully I'm beyond and the PAS who
have moved on beyond health care again I
think this is just so intimate to what
Yale has given us in addition to our
medical education for that drive and
desire to make more of ourselves and
people like Ann who have served at the
highest levels of government with the
surgeon general's office and and pas who
have served in many
capacities and and it is more than just
the water that we drink here at Yale and
and I think that this program has
contributed this aspect to the PA
profession every bit as much as it has
to the great clinical pas that we have
had because although we've talked about
it I really asked you to stop for a
minute and think about your practice
especially for you newer people that
weren't don't have to practice in the
kind of situation that we did that
Berlin Burdine talked about of where
nurses absolutely refuse to take our
orders and we had to work around that
situation I would think about doing that
today where we just take for granted put
them in whether it's electronically or
otherwise you put it in and it's and
it's done there was a time when that was
not possible there was a time when we
could not write prescriptions and I
don't know if we're being recorded but
you know we would use pre-signed
prescriptions in order to just get
through the day kind of thing not for
ourselves but for the further patients
and some for ourselves as well as Dick
said but um you know again think about
your day-to-day work without being able
to write prescriptions for those things
that are working clinically the change
has just been tremendous we had no
licensure we were barely recognized in
the law with a very general delegate to
our law but one that probably created
more confusion than then helped us yeah
we didn't have a certification exam
which again for me was maybe not all
that bad but we got a certificate
booking is right I became a grandfather
at a very early age because the state
was kind enough to grandfather me into
the law when we got licensure but you
know we got a certificate no degree
whatsoever Burdine and I were sitting
last night talking about the early days
and we could literally list every PA
that was in Connecticut at the time that
we started and there were about six of
us at that time six of us in the entire
state practicing as pas so you know it
just was an incredible time and and I
think again Yale helped us to get
involved in our organizations to give us
that drive to do that and
going to let my colleagues here talk a
little bit about what it was that that
we did with that well I I want to thank
Mary for for the invitation and it's
it's it's a little spooky being back
here I have to say remembering my
interview I cried all the way home I was
sure that I would not be accepted and I
this is where I really wanted to come
once I was here I was totally miserable
of course with the classes after my
first two weeks in the anatomy class and
dr. kreelan saying ah the first test is
just going to be on the big bones I took
him literally do you know how many
facets he tested us on Justin that one
skeletal system exam and so the bar was
set high very very early on but I have
to say it served me well my mother was a
little confused when I told her that I
wanted to become a PA when I was
applying for programs but when I got
into Yale she said oh I guess it's I
guess it's a legitimate profession and
she has always been proud of me ever
since then there was a turning point in
our relationship in terms of my
direction in life when I got into Yale
to the PA program and and but it did it
did set the bar for expectations and the
people that were here Bruce and Jeff and
Alain and Burdine in particular were
there with their roles in the American
Academy of physician assistants were not
only encouraging us but urging us and
pushing us to go to our first conference
in our first year and it was an
eye-opener and I got invited in and I
saw that this was something that I I
could participate in that was that was
fun and interesting and I immediately
ran for the Student Academy because they
would pay my transportation to the next
meeting and I found out how I could have
free food so that i could get free not
free seeing me i still had to pay
registration but I could get cm
and learn about this profession but it
wasn't until I got out of practice in my
first job in a hospital where I in Cape
Cod Hyannis hospital Cape Cod Hospital
in Hyannis where where I had done in
internal medicine rotation and here i
was now as a as a PA in a in a internal
medicine nephrology practice where now
the nurses wouldn't take my orders it
was the same kind of thing that that was
described earlier and I I was horrified
that first of all I was deeply in debt
because I couldn't get loans to come to
to do this incredible training that I so
believed in the profession and that I
was so eager and passionate about it and
yet my hands were tied and I was hobbled
and sometimes muzzled and it was it was
very frustrating to me but I found great
strength in numbers with the aapa and
with getting very quickly involved with
the massachusetts association of PAS
where I was and Barbara it's nice to see
you here who was also very very involved
with that that that I at that time it
was it was you know the scope of
practice it was the same thing this was
I was a 1980s graduate and they were we
barely had we were we were able to
practice in the state but in a very
limited way we had no prescriptive
privileges and we set that as our goal
that we were going to get prescriptive
privileges I don't remember how many
years it took us because some of us you
know sort of died on the way side but we
just kept going and kept thinking we're
going to outlive the mass medical
society and we are going to get this
legislation through and you know we
finally did but it was there are many
other struggles for a recognition that I
think drew us together very in a very
positive way that makes this a very very
special profession I think 22 probably
all of you here and MIT and you know
look at how the profession has grown
it's truly incredible but I I thank Yale
for kind of setting the bar for
leadership I have to say when I was a
student and I got involved with a
student academy I was student academy
president during my second year of
rotations
and how could anybody find any time to
do anything else it gave me a really
nice balance and what I discovered was
that I loved practicing medicine but i
also love organizing people and things
and organizations and that experience
with the student academy and with the
aapa helped me develop those skills that
I've now used in what some would call a
confusing career because it's a zigzag
every dot connects but every but it
zigzags so I because I'm a little bit
unusual I'll just tell you a little bit
about about the zigs and the Zags is
that i was in PA practice but as i got
involved i started taking night jobs in
an emergency room with an HMO so that i
could lobby for the PAS in massachusetts
to get that prescriptive privileges to
free up my day time to be be at the
Statehouse so much so that the Senate
chairman of the health care committee
asked me if i wanted to work for him and
I said sure as long as I can moonlight
on the weekends and I did that for quite
a while a few years and then got an
opportunity to I was hired to be the
director of a city public health
department in somerville massachusetts
still moonlighting on the weekends and
at that at that time i was involved with
the aapa i was on the board i got
elected president when i was director of
the Somerville health department and it
was during the Clinton health care
reform days and that's my claim to fame
with the PA profession Bruce is still
jealous and I like to remind him of that
that I got to meet hillary and bill and
I have this slides that I promise not to
show but I'll paint you a picture I
called I called I went around the
country so i don't know if any of you
were living then and saw some of the the
inspirational talks that we had about
how p a's were part of what could really
help expand primary care to the millions
of Americans who needed access to
healthcare and part of the reason why i
was able to do that was because of my
experience in the state where we
couldn't just lobby for PA prescriptive
villages who cares whether pas get to do
this or that why do they need to do it
because people need the health care and
we joined with other organizations
no the elderly organizations the
community organizations the access
healthcare access organizations that
helped us make our case much better than
we could just in isolation about why are
we here anyway what what's the point of
medical care and what's the what's the
point of of an expanded workforce and we
were able to make that very clearly so I
got to go to some of the White House
things and I got to be testified before
the White House Task Force on on health
care reform back in 93 when we thought
we'd get health care reform then that
was a while ago it didn't pass but we
got some some great recognition at that
time and since then the profession has
just gone up even without health care
reform because there was such a need I
mean you look at the statistics that the
Patrick showed and it's just so
impressive how really a meteoric rise
for the PA profession but we still have
our problems and I think some of the
lessons and some of the some of the
things some of the ways that we need to
keep moving are along the same ones you
outlined some very nice things that that
we still need to be getting
reimbursement and recognition so that we
can offer what we have to offer and
that's where I think all of us still
have a role in the PA program still have
a very strong role in joining together
to find the best way to turn around some
of those misconceptions about how we can
be a huge part of the solution to a cost
effective healthcare system and so it's
very inspirational but I was going to
tell you some of my zigs and zags and I
left off as a Somerville health
department person but I'm telling you
this because here i was i was a APA
president i was also the director of a
health department we had some very
surprising tobacco control legislation
that we got passed in our city that
became a state model and then you know
along the way it was it was kind of very
exciting to move beyond just being a
health care provider to thinking i can
not only take care of patients one on
one but from a public health perspective
i want to look at the populations health
and what's needed that I see patients
coming in to me every day with things
that could have been prevented or they
could have had earlier diagnosis and
treatment
and shouldn't we all be looking it that
way I went on to have be offered a new
position after a number of years there
in to direct a similar department in
Portland Maine for their for their
health department at the same time they
were having tobacco control legislation
which then became state legislation
which was fantastic but then I got this
most amazing opportunity that came
together because the PA foundation was
able to create funding to create a
fellowship in the office of the Surgeon
General for the first PA in the office
of the Surgeon General ever and so I
jumped at it and went to Washington I'd
said to my new husband of two and a half
years well you always said you'd support
me and watch going to Washington he said
yeah but I didn't say I'd lived there so
he loved me too and so I commuted for a
couple years back and forth every week
pretty much I had the most amazing
experience every time that we did
anything having to do with the release
of a surgeon general's report or a
launch on a new public health initiative
we made sure that representatives of
aapa and the PA profession were always
on the guest list they hadn't been
before that and that continues to this
day because we've got you on the you
know we're on the we're on the guest
list now and in fact I started
organizing some of those things and
really making sure that that they were
there and it was you know all kinds of
public important public health issues
that that's not subject to this talk but
along along the way there my funding
ended they hired me as a consultant that
funding ended that Surgeon General David
Satcher who's still an inspiration in my
eyes moved moved on and I packed up and
went home got the call almost
immediately we've got this new
congressional funding for a surgeon
general's report on bone health and
osteoporosis do you want to take it on
and so they did they hired me to
coordinate this whole project and then I
hooked up with a consulting company to
do parts of it that actually had a
little office a little satellite office
in Portland Maine how perfect so I could
do that work living in my beautiful
place working doing doing national
policy
work and then put that report out in
2004 and a few years later an
opportunity came up to they were looking
for a new executive director of the
American Society for bone and mineral
research and I jumped at it because
these are the these these are the
physicians and researchers who study
osteoporosis and related metabolic bone
diseases their mission although it's a
research mission to do the basic and
clinical research a growing part of
their mission is the translation of
their great discoveries into clinical
practice and for me that pulls it all
together the individual patients and the
endpoint and the whole line of continuum
they're now looking at what are the
system based interventions to improve
somebody's care early in childhood while
they're still building their bone mass
and children that have chronic diseases
what is that doing to their accretion of
their bone mass all the way through the
continuum of men and women developing
osteoporosis and related diseases later
on that could have been prevented by
better better exercise and nutrition and
medication when they needed it and and
they're looking at you know here's a
group of scientists and research
physicians looking at how can we do
public awareness campaigns now because
we want to see our treatment get into
you know our discoveries get into
practice much more and most of you who
know that know that osteoporosis is
still a very silent disease even in your
own offices perhaps I hope not but it's
I've seen it we see these people walking
around all the time i remember when i
was here at yale looking at a lateral
chest x-ray and the the the senior
residents saying you know osteoporosis
incidental finding next and that was it
so so I tell you I tell you all of these
kind of stories to give you a context
for what my yellow education it did to
me too because practicing medicine is
really important to practice with the
best evidence and and put it into
practice but it's more than that it's
looking at your whole community and your
patients in the environment where they
live and what keeps them healthy and how
you can help them when they're when
they're not healthy and and I think that
Yale made a huge difference for me in
marrying the medicine and the public
health and I hope it has for all of you
too so I'll turn it over to Cindy I'm
not going behind there i stand behind
there all week as a teacher so i do want
to thank mary and all the PA faculty
here for inviting me i was very honored
to be invited and certainly to thank
anne and the Saddlers for and Jack hole
for that vision ok I don't know what
that was for having the vision to start
the program you know you can read my bio
this isn't about here's what i did i am
going to choose a little something
different to share with you or challenge
you that are our yale not mine this is
just the way Mary sliced the data with
Dave she could have sliced the data and
every one of you would have been up here
whether you're a committee chair a
patient educator and activist so there
is nothing special about as well Bruce
is special but aside from that aside
from that we're all special and and
that's because of our education but each
of us could have each of you could have
been up here so all of us what our
education has given to us and so I just
like to share three ideas which first is
responsibility and obligation the next
for me is maturity and taking that
responsibility and I call it the putting
on your big girl panties effect and the
other is kind of that moving forward how
we help patients and I think that's what
our Yale experience has given to us from
the day I came like an i brought my
husband who said why do you want to hold
the stethoscope for a doctor and I
consider myself a third-generation PA
I'm not of the prehistoric I'm an 80s
person they late 80s so I'm a
third-generation and I realized that
things had already been done for me but
we came and Bruce and putting others
first is my other one that I'll talk
about and there was Bruce at the Elaine
had the open house and
came for that information session and
Bruce got up there and he talked about
you know here's how many I got wrong on
the pants exam membered he dropped the
paper and all the wrong ones were there
and I failed it and you don't have a
blah blah and the next thing he said was
if you have the word I more than three
times in your essay this isn't the place
for you and I ran home and I said oh my
God look at all the eyes in my essay and
I took them all out and that was my
first step into realizing if me myself
and I are your three best friends this
isn't the place for you at Yale and
medicine isn't the place for you so that
was lesson one me myself and I not my
three best friends the next was
obligation and responsibility and
nowhere in the handbook and it was a red
three ring binder that Elaine had I
remember I probably just threw it away
recently you know I can't throw away
your Yale stuff Fred said you know
somebody could be down in the ground I
went to Yale you tell somebody so then
that three ring binder but nowhere is
there anywhere that says obligation or
responsibility yet it's there for all of
us with whatever you do whether it's
your advocacy whether its leadership at
the state or national level whether it's
teaching in the hospital or teaching in
a formal setting like a university we
have that obligation to be the leaders
in whatever we do and would ever feel
and that came through my experience here
and Elaine didn't whip us you must do
this you must do that but I too like an
raised my hand and said I'd like to run
for going to be the representative from
Yale and went to the National Academy
representing a land aor assembly of
Representatives and I got there and got
caught up by the fever there's all these
happy people and this PA thing was like
wow this is great I really enjoy this
and ran for the board and and bruising
and Jeff came along and there you know
you're like oh my god there's fathers of
our profession and they came up to me
and they said Cindy we vote for you and
I'm like they don't even know me but
they said they'd vote for me though they
couldn't vote so it was a really free
thing they were offering Marian only
students could vote right so there was
you know again that obligation was there
but it was never written you just felt
it the fact that you know there were no
hundred pages of notes there was not
even PowerPoint at the time
but you had that obligation to learn
when dr. Goff / walked in to do our
vascular lecture and he came in his you
know hadn't even taken his booties off
yet he had his mass good enough on his
head and he said what's three-block
claudication and we all SAT there like
that and and dr. Duffy came in and said
you did read my book didn't you before
you came to class and were like and you
did you just went home and you learned
this no one was spoon-feeding you and no
one said we're going to spoon-feed who
you or not you just did it because you
had to do it and you so there was that
obligation and and the third was that
you have this responsibility so you have
that kind of put on your big girl
panties no one was going to spoon feed
you so those are the things that have
kind of carried me forward into what we
need to do and what our obligations are
and always focused on patient care and
the other was kind of giving back to
society and not not about myself with
that giving back and so those are the
kind of the tenants that I've used in my
life as I've moved on and I had great
mentorship you know that was the other
thing that came at Yale they didn't say
here on your mentor and forcing you to
be my mentor it just happened and did I
go into education that was not on my
list primary care wasn't on my list but
when I got elected to the student board
I was the APAP sap a liaison and so
between elaine and ruth ball wig and
tony miller these people who you know
because teachers at that time right your
professors were those are the mean
people who wrote those horrible exams
you would study for but they didn't ask
the questions that you would study and I
realized working with them on the Paea
which was formerly a pat board wow they
really cared they struggled more with
students than we struggled with liking
them they were worried about us and
wanted us to be the best we could be and
so that was my inspiration to go into
education because I had good mentors and
they never wore it every never wore it
on her sleeve Ruth never said here on
your mentor and you owe me and I'm doing
there was never the I word it just
happened it was natural and they did it
for their love and their passion and so
hopefully those are the things that I'm
trying to carry forward as doing the APA
again it was that very first day we got
here I don't think we were here a week
and Elaine how to stop at four in the
morning on a bus to New Jersey and all I
remember is this Mary and remus lady on
the steps of the New Jersey
capital and there we were I was this
young person marching on the capital to
help New Jersey get their rights and so
you know again this obligation is there
because it was just part of year old you
know jack Pikeville kohlhepp Bruce they
those it was just we were just getting
licensure I mean the fact that I'm 00000
53 not bad for the new kid on the block
that's my license number but it's
because they literally were sleeping on
the capital and they didn't say and you
owe me it was nothing about them it was
this is for all of us for patient care
and they always had patient care there
so that's always been kind of what's you
know has propelled me forward and having
those good mentors who who just did it
and they did it for others not for
themselves my work with the Academy
these guys had set a lot of the work the
you know last night for Dean and
Marianne and Elaine sharing stories of
how everything came together in the
House of Delegates and you know what
they used to do with those all-night
meetings I wanted those all night
meetings that's why I joined but the
camaraderie the friendship at the same
time being able to move our profession
forward was an honor for me as well so
it's nothing you should take for granted
it's always an honor it's a privilege
and honor to practice medicine and it's
an honor to be a PA so those are the
things that have driven made the Academy
and doing the APA and being president
again I had all this done before me so
our goal was you know when you had to
fight with did the Yale even know who
you were and should it be a program and
then people don't the nurses and the
state no one knew what you were that was
all ready for us so as I was president
in the Academy it was about advocacy
what does the world know and how can we
better connect them because they know
the word PA and then of course you start
to drill down and we become a lot of
different things the minute you say so
what is a PA to you so it really was
about advocacy so I'm going to leave it
short because I know you all are you
getting hungry but it's our
responsibility it's putting patients
first me myself and I are not my three
best friends and it is an honor to
practice medicine and congratulations to
all of you because we all
long in that same cloth
are there questions was you're going to
go to the National to go there
it still is too that's good news are
there other questions comments okay I
parting last words anything that you'd
like to add now that you've heard each
other's presentations more than once I
would only say it not think that it is
over and i would pay as much as we might
have accomplished there is a lot of
personal satisfaction of being a part of
that and have a bit about i just want to
encourage it's not too late and as
patrick said there's still plenty to be
done is not a perfect profession in
terms of what we can do we'll be able to
do at some point if you haven't thought
about being about you so you'll be well
rewarded with my comics would be many
years ago
steen I the paf auction they used to
have I've been on doctor says
beautifully browned doctor said I kind
of help it ron Nelson who's ten times
more money than i'll ever appt something
exciting husband know how much you're
going to take got back to work it was
the picture of dr. stead kind in my
office it was a Saturday trying to catch
up the phone rings I thought was my
husband Brett saying when you coming
home it's yet again Saturday and you're
working and I picked up the phone and
the person said yeah and I was just
sitting there and we have this
conversation for over an hour and it
amazed me his vision of where we need to
go in his vision of who we are in our
role in health care is beyond any of us
and so we have a lot more to do to reach
that at that pinnacle and he had that
vision and articulated 95 years old we
should never lose that bite in that fire
a little voice in my head saying there's
more to do and you can do it and don't
let anyone stop you so all operational
ever since my first year but i'll tell
you all the
research ends things came back to me
over the years in a number of ways and
there's one particular patient that I
had that I think really exemplified it
because she talked a lot maybe she did
to you about when you have an elderly
person that's you know kind of comfrey
lat ill and you know they just you don't
really know who they are you know you
look at them and you might be tempted to
treat the one day older person but they
think of themselves as they were when
they were younger and it has served me
well with my patients the politicians
that I deal with policymakers as well
that they have a vision of themselves a
word when they were at their most vital
and at the patient that I remember most
was sitting in her hospital bed every
morning with her Johnny and her pearls
on and when I did my x-ray rounds every
morning I could see her hurt her her
chest x-ray across the room because it
that's how she captures dignity and so I
thank you for that and for personalizing
the Edison and the connection of love it
all means and why why we're doing this
is for